[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d'un dernier
interdit je reçois aujourd'hui françois
bégaudeau pour son nouveau livre notre
joie aux éditions pover qui est la suite
d'histoires de ta bêtise paru il ya deux
ans et on commence tout de suite par
l'image que vous avez choisi pour
symboliser notre époque
cette image barnier dans des familiers
maintenant un oui là l'image est pas
très original bon notre époque notre
époque est confuse après je me demande
toujours si notre époque est
particulièrement confuse
je pense que toutes les époques se vit
toujours comme un peu confuse mais la
nôtre a quand même cette caractéristique
de d'avoir fait émerger énormément de
d'éditorialistes de leaders d'opinion
d'intellectuels ou prétendus tels qu'ils
ont l'art de semer la confusion ils le
font en brandissant des mots des mots
creux fourre tout dans lequel on peut
mettre absolument tous les contenus
possibles alors par exemple liberté en
est un en liberté c'est un mot qui alors
déjà est très compliqué
anthropologiquement mais dont je vois
pas exactement quel usage il peut avoir
en politique puisqu'il s'agit de ça si
en tout cas on leur enlevant le réduit à
lui même il faut toujours y est ajouté
quelque chose on parlait de la liberté
d'expression par exemple ou de circuler
et dans ces cas-là on s'apercevra que le
problème est surtout l'expression et non
pas la liberté donc bon ça ne m'étonne
pas du tout d'avoir entendu hier marine
le pen le brandir en étendard c'est son
mot clé c'est son élément de langage de
rentrée c'est normal venant du parti de
la confusion que l'extrême droite a
toujours été un parti confusionniste et
et là c'est un peu normal de l'avoir
retrouvé comme mot fédérateur du
mouvement anti passe ou des manifs anti
passe bons qui sont des manifs
relativement confus je pense bon mais on
voit bien que quand on dire l'objet
n'est pas l'art c'est-à-dire que dès
lors que vous parlez de liberté vous
êtes toujours en train de parler d'autre
chose et ça fait toujours écran par
rapport à un autre problème là en
l'occurrence je les ressens caricaturer
ce mouvement pour lesquelles j'ai pas
d'antipathie particulière je crois que
ce qui fédère ces gens avant tout c'est
quand même le sentiment globalement je
vais trop vite que le vaccin est plus
dangereux que le virus
finalement quoi en tout cas c'est ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'il y a ces
gens font un certain diagnostic sur le
réel est donc sous couvert de défendre
la liberté ils promeuvent un certain
diagnostic sur le réel qu'on peut
contester donc le problème en politique
c'est toujours ça c'est la question
centrale de la politique en virant tous
ces gros mots là qui nous embarrasse
l'esprit c'est que c'est toujours qu'en
est il du réel c'est la seule question
est bien on va en parler entrons
maintenant dans le vif du sujet dom peur
[Musique]
l'histoire de ta bêtise dont vous étiez
venu parler dans cette émission il ya
deux ans était un réquisitoire contre la
bourgeoisie libérale qui nous qui vous
reprocher de ne pas avoir fait barrage à
marine le pen en
2017 en votant pour emmanuel macron
voulu expliquer notamment que selon vous
le pire qui nous menaçait et qui nous
menace en notant qu'aujourd'hui ce
n'était pas la famille le pen qui en
était responsable
c'était la bourgeoisie libérale c'est à
dire les électeurs des manuels macron
notre joie c'est la suite quand vous
vous apercevez que parmi vos lecteurs et
vos thuriféraires il y à des électeurs
de marine le pen dé soutien d'alain
soral des souverainistes ou des
identitaires vous en rencontrez
quelques-uns à lyon un soir après une
rencontre publique ce sont des jeunes à
qui vous avec qui vous allez prendre un
verre ils ont vraiment existé ou cela
procédés littéraires non ils ont
vraiment existé et je alors après on
n'est pas censé y croire mais je la file
en 6 mois je vous croyais à riom
faudrait peut-être témoigner eux mêmes
non mais c'était bien pour moi puisque
j'ai un peu de mal à écrire des essais
qui serait comme ça hors sol parce que
c'est toujours un peu de danger les
essais théoriques c'est que maman
d'école un peu et on se retrouve à
brandir des mots comme liberté par
exemple donc là j'avais ça faisait
quelques mois que je méditais de faire
un livre un petit peu autour de ça
autour de ce malentendu entre les gens
vous allez plus ou moins égrainé et moi
et là j'ai eu ma situation j'ai une
situation qui m'est tombé dessus comme
un cadeau du ciel savoir ces jeunes gens
plutôt soraliens je dirais pour aller
bosser approximatif mais chassez alicia
tuera un peu qu'ils me manifeste une
grande amitié quoi oui vous êtes mon
idole nous est tout à fait plus qu'une
amitié même et donc je rigole un peu
devant leur comment dire leur hyperbole
mais j'accepte les verts puisque je moi
je suis toujours prêt à boire des coups
et tout le monde est cette soirée va
être vraiment passionnant parce que je
vais pouvoir vérifier c'est le premier
héros du livre d'ailleurs je pouvoir
vérifier ce soir là certes on de
d'intuition que j'avais sur sur ce genre
d'esprit sur qu'est ce qui se passe dans
leur tête à ces gens là et à quel degré
de confusion ils en sont arrivés là près
reparti avec confusion pour me trouver
pour trouver que je puisse être leur
idole alors que j'ai quand même toujours
manifesté assez clairement je pense mon
mon affiliation au camp opposé donc
c'est ça c'est l' enquête que je n'en
fais tu sais les extrêmes ne se
rejoignent pas vraiment pas les extrêmes
de ce rejoignent vraiment pas aucun
égard alors évidemment ils ont un point
commun mais ce qui est un faux point
commun c'est une mauvaise piste pour
produire de la politique ce qui a pu
leur faire croire qu'on pouvait être
amis c'est que nous avons des ennemis
communs en tout cas ce que appellerait
des amis parce que moi je préfère parler
de l'adversaire je n'aime pas beaucoup
la notion d'inimitié en politique des
adversaires des adversaires de classe
par exemple effectivement comme j'avais
commis un livre un peu un peu grinçant
et un peu offensif sur la bourgeoisie y
compris la bourgeoisie centriste donc
bourgeoisie de gauche de droite etc
c'est ces gens plutôt d'extrême droite
pouvait croire qu'on avait un ennemi
commun puisque se répandent en général
contre cette bourgeoisie la bourgeoisie
coup la bourgeoisie un peu bien pensants
dire et ils eux mêmes et donc qu'ils ont
considéré que les ennemis de leurs
ennemis pouvait être leur ami et ça je
pense que c'est une très très mauvaise
ou moins politique qui d'ailleurs
actuellement fait beaucoup de mal je
vois moi beaucoup se se coaliser des
gens dont le seul point commun est une
inimitié commune je pense pas qu'on
puisse fabriquer de la politique
d'émancipation à partir des limites et
comme une autre alors chez chez ces gens
face auquel vous vous retrouvez un soir
à lyon vous
apercevez que l'identité fait partie de
leurs références comme les traditions
comme le patriotisme ils se disent
patriotes et tout ça pour vous c'est de
la fantasmagorie un haut-fond sont des
mots mais ça n'existe pas dans les faits
oui oui ce qui me frappe chez eux mais
ce qui m'a toujours frappé ce qui me
frappe chez soral par exemple pour
prendre leurs vraies idoles leur idole
historique parce que là je pense que
j'ai eu à faire ce soir là des jeunes
gens de 25 ans qui sont déjà les
premiers enfants de soral sera là a
produit énormément de d'émules en tout
cas de de continuateur et on se rend
compte que maintenant je crois de leur
importance véritable tellement parce
qu'ils l'ont lu d'ailleurs mais parce
qu'ils l'ont vu dans une vidéo
g sur son canapé je pense que les gens
quelle jolie affaire avait eu quinze ans
ils ont commencé à regarder des vidéos
youtube de soral à l'époque à ça les a
formés comme moi il m'est arrivé d'être
formés en lisant j'ai pas giono et
deleuze à 18 ans enfin ce genre de
choses ils ont déconné c'est d'ailleurs
dans ce livre qu'il est très performant
sera le vous dit aussi qu'il arrive à
une espèce d'intellectualisme pur que
doivent lui envier pas mal
d'intérimaires bien sûr il arrive et
apprécié des légions par les mots tout à
fait c'est un très bon orateur un bon
raider c'est quelqu'un qui produit
beaucoup de penser qu'il ya une espèce
de production de penser chez lui une
production conceptuel mais qui
essentiellement verbal quoi c'est
pourquoi sa déconstruction verbal est
effectivement qui manipulent ce qui nous
reviendrait ce que j'ai sur l'a10 versé
par exemple kaki qui mobilise et qui
manipule des entités conceptuel qui pour
moi sont absolument vide de réalité je
dirais alors l'identité
l'identité par exemple bons mots qui
assume mes interlocuteurs de ce soir là
ils brandissent l'identité d'ailleurs
précédemment dans la rencontre publique
que je venais de faire
rencontre après laquelle ils m'ont
interpellé l'un d'eux m'avait posé comme
question et ça résume bien le libellé
était celui là et sinon identité comme
si vraiment il fallait se positionner
sur espèce de mots un peu intransitif
comme ça que c'est pas l'identité donc
je leur ai demandé quel contenu vous y
mettez est en fait je comprend deux
choses en tout cas je vérifie de choses
en les écoutant soir là c'est que
premièrement évidemment que le mot
identité n'a aucun contenu mais que
deuxièmement il faut surtout qu'ils n'en
aient pas voilà et que c'est ça qui leur
importe c'est à dire que plus un mot
absente le réel plus ils vont avoir
tendance à le brandir parce que eux ce
qui les intéresse surtout c'est que
c'est que le réel soit évacuée et donc
effectivement d'identité qui était un
pari intenable puisque sa rentrée dans
nos logis un peu a musclé mais le réel
c'est ce qui diffère le réel c'est ce
qui diffère en naissant jeudi faire de
ma mère par exemple enfin bon nous
différons tous les uns des autres si
nous voulons absolument ramener un
certain nombre de corps à une identité
alors il faut absolument de mentir sur
ces corps donc la notion d'identité elle
repose sur un mensonge et la promotion
identitaire a absolument besoin
d'abstraire le discours de la réalité
mais ça serait vrai aussi de la patrie
je dirais tri est ce que ce serait de la
culture y at il pas une spécificité de
la culture française des manières
française
on parle de la galanterie française
survenu il ya quelques temps on en a
reparlé parce que j'étais un peu tombé
en désuétude mais au fond la culture
plus exactement va très bien mais après
prenons des exemples un parent et voyons
qu'il implique véritablement très
intéressant vous prenez l'exemple de la
galanterie française par exemple chose
qui a été par exemple promu et je ne dis
pas ça pour la disqualifier les jeux de
notes par finkielkraut figure comptes a
beaucoup parlé d'un certain rapport au
féminin dans la culture française vichy
mais surtout claude et bip qui avait
écrit à travers ce livre tout acheté
c'était absolument dans la continuité de
claude habib mais de quoi parle est il à
ce moment-là il parlait d'une certaine
aristocratie du xviiie il parlait d'une
certaine haute bourgeoisie émergente du
xviiie c'était la galanterie de salon
qui effectivement peut avoir son charme
et qui peut-être a caractérisé peut-être
à un moment
l'aristocratie du xviiie français
cependant que l'ensemble de la
population française 90% de la
population restante c'était des gueux
paysans qui n'avaient pas dedans et où
régnaient je pense pas exactement
beaucoup plus de galanterie qu en
allemagne où ce qui allait devenir
l'allemagne par la suite au même moment
en italie où n'importe quel coin du
monde donc il faut toujours divisé on
voit bien qu'à chaque fois qu'on veut
identifier quelque chose comme étant un
trait de la culture française on
s'aperçoit que c'est un trait d'une sous
population de
cette entité territoriale qui s'appelle
la france quoi quand on dit et après il
y aurait une deuxième chose sur la
culture française une chose est de
éventuellement constater que nous autres
habitants de ce territoire nous aurions
des traits culturels comme un bon par
exemple nous aimons le pain nous
fabriquons beaucoup de pain nous en
mangeons beaucoup et puis décroissant
par exemple c'est un trait culturel qui
nous est relativement commun à tous les
65 millions de français à quelques
exceptions près est ce que pour autant
je dois valoriser cette culture est ce
que est ce que alors la valoriser en
terme de préservation de la culture oui
bien sûr moi je suis pour qu'on préserve
des cultures je suis pour qu'on préserve
les chants corses je trouve ça très beau
c'est ça va être ça appartient au
patrimoine de l'humanité autant que
possible préservons les langues aussi
intéressant de préserver la langue
bretonne c'est un trésor une langue mais
de là à la valoriser politiquement ccc
l'alleud problème c'est que vraiment je
vais constituer un imaginaire politique
est un projet politique à partir de la
baguette de pain et du croissant vous à
partir du coq au vin vraiment pas et
c'est là que
l'éventuelle identification de quelque
chose qui pourrait être la culture
française ne peut en être en aucun cas
une valeur politique or c'est bien
l'erreur que font alors l'extrême droite
la droite le centre beaucoup de gens
quand même mais a quand même énormément
de gens qui brandissent alors par
exemple nos valeurs notre culture comme
étant des piliers de leur programme
politique à celle accepte le bât blesse
et c'est là que même ça peut même tout à
fait mal tourné le jour où ces gens là
prennent le pouvoir
et conseillers et s'est dirigé en
politique leurs options culturelles ou
leur défense de certains traits
culturels
en général je pense que ça produit
beaucoup plus d'exclusion que de liesse
françois bégaudeau ont ils sauvé une
d'ostalgie de la france quand on parle
de l'identité
vous dites que c'est pas tellement à la
france qui a changé c'est la langue qui
sait déboutonnée là encore ce ne serait
que du langage mais au fond c'est ici
uniquement c'est uniquement verbales
mais moi je pense qu'il ya des deux
parties d'avoir eu mon livre t garder
deux parties cette première partie mais
dans un premier temps j'essaie de
prendre mes interlocuteurs auxquels j'ai
eu affaire essentiellement comme des
sujets parlant puisque on discutait au
café grand sport national français oui
alors allé en terrasse est un trait
culturel français souffrent il ya des
gens qui aiment pas du tout elle en
terrasse bon il faut le dire quand même
voilà il en a dit dimanche à l'ats les
réseaux sociaux on peut discuter
absolument bon on est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas là donc j'ai bien d'affaires
adea des parleurs et je me rends compte
qu'ils aiment bien parler moi aussi cela
dit et voilà c'est surtout bon mais
c'est vrai que je prends d'abord ce lieu
politique qui serait la droite
autoritaire
où la pensée identitaire où la pensée
autoritaire en général comme un comme un
phénomène linguistique parce
qu'effectivement je pense que c'est
d'abord un phénomène qui ce soutien de
sa langue et que j'appelle une langue
autoritaire et sur quoi fait-elle
autorités cette langue elle fait
autorité sur le réel c'est à dire que si
vous imposez le mot identité au réel
vous évacuer le réel et ce serait vrai
d'à peu près tous les énoncés qui le
prononce mais quand même dans un
deuxième moment jeu j'essaie de montrer
en marque si ce que je demeure que que
les phénomènes linguistiques sont eux
mêmes la projection d'un d'une certaine
position sociale et c'est à dire que là
on revient quand même à la matière et la
matière c'est qu'au bout du compte ces
gens
pour la plupart sont quand même des gens
pour certains en tout cas issue de la
bourgeoisie est très soucieux quand bon
bourgeois de conserver leurs privilèges
et leurs intérêts ou alors ce sont des
gens qui mais bon bout
stigmatiser ou comment dire brocardé
l'ordre social existant en fait ils en
sont totalement les défenseurs donc je
pense que la passion première c'est
quand même toujours un peu de conserver
ce qui est est de conserver par exemple
l'ordre social et de ce point de vue là
je ne fais aucune différence et je le
dis clairement je ne fais aucune
différence entre la droite et l'extrême
droite aucune différence entre les
libéraux et l'extrême droite finalement
alliés objectifs pour conserver l'ordre
social
l'identitaire dites-vous veut ce qu'il
dénonce les territoires perdus de la
république par exemple il est veut y les
désirs ou est-ce que sans les
territoires perdus de la république
il a plus rien à dire bien sûr alors ça
va essayer c'est là qu'on prend dans des
perversions passionnante et vertigineuse
je pense parce que moi ça me frappait
beaucoup
jeunes gens pas dans le livre rouge
décrivait venait de sortir cette femme
de conversations whatsapp entre entre
des flics 1 qui avait été chopé par
libération mediapart où c'est plus est
donc bon public un peu facho qui qui
paraît de la guerre civile de l'ambiance
dans les quartiers et que les quartiers
était à feu et à sang qu'il fallait
intervenir qu'il fallait remettre de
l'ordre dans tout ça est et l'un des
interlocuteurs témoignait non pas du
fait qu' on allait on allait à grand pas
vers la guerre civile mais il disait
qu'il l'a souhaitait et donc je pense
que tous ces gens qui font toujours leur
diagnostic et leur souhaite bien sûr que
certains d'entre eux souhaitent le grand
affrontement notamment avec les
quartiers populaires à forte coloration
disons by grattoir là disons le comme ça
en gros les trucs où il ya des noirs et
les arabes quoi genre les quartiers nord
de marseille pour prendre ce qui est à
la mode mais plein d'autres quartiers
ces quartiers sont quand même appelé par
valérie pécresse pas par adolf hitler
pas part d'eric zemmour pas par marine
le pen ils sont appelés ces quartiers
des zones de non france c'est valérie
pécresse une libérale bontinck il le dit
c'est pas moi bon je note quand même et
donc il s'agit effectivement de de
confondre un tout petit peu oui le le
constat est le désir ces gens là
constate ceux qui le désirent et il
désire effectivement le grand
affrontement en l'occurrence les flics
désiré le moment où une certaine un
certain état irréversible disons deux
dans certains cas ou dans les banlieues
légitimerait le fait qu'il puisse y
intervenir sans frein entre temps j'ai
fini d'écrire mon livre depuis un
certain temps mais entre temps nous
avons eu les tribunes de militaires du
disait à peu près la même chose en fait
dont on ne s'est jamais distingué
effectivement le désiraient constat ces
gens là ont très clairement envie d'un
affrontement ils ont envie d'aller faire
la peau assez assez assez jeunes gens
arabes et noirs qui visiblement les
rendent un peu fou voilà donc ils
désirent la guerre civile qu'ils ont
l'air de réprouver vous dit également
que la république les valeurs de la
république les lois de la république dès
qu'on met le mot république là dedans ça
a été récupéré par tous les défenseurs
de l'autorité au fond un qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient de droite d'extrême droite
sans doute aussi de gauche ou en tout
cas il estime d'être de gauche peut être
que vous leur refuseriez ça mais mais on
va dire que chez vous ça va de jean
michel blanquer gérald darmanin manuel
valls génie bastié lisa ben nevis
zemmour marine le pen marion maréchal au
fond c'est le bloc autoritaire c'est le
bloc autoritaire qui est je le répète
bien un bloc bourgeois qui est quand
même toujours très attentif à défendre
l'ordre social d'ailleurs qui qui qui a
essentiellement des cibles qui sont
issus des quartiers populaires qui sont
en temps qu'ils sont issus de la classe
inférieure
leurs cibles sont toujours soin des
prolos soit des gens qui sont qui font
métier politique de défendre le
prolétariat ou les classes populaires
moi je n'entends dans ce bloc
autoritaire cas qu'une nouvelle
extension une nouvelle resucée du bloc
bourgeois et effectivement ce bloc
autoritaires ou sept arches autoritaire
je veux dire elle est très large et
c'est effectivement large de ces gens
qui ont mis le mot république cette
espèce d'incantation creuse au milieu de
leurs discours politique à partir des
années 80 est d'ailleurs en dans le dans
le négatif des premières à faire du
voile ou d'une certaine pensée
autoritaire sur l'école c'est elle et
régis debray c'était alain finkielkraut
c'est elle elisabeth badinter et depuis
tout ça s'est constitué une espèce de
blocs républicain et on a vu de plus en
plus clairement que ce mot de république
qui a un sens dans l'histoire qui
pourrait être un sens d'ailleurs noble
un prêt noble d'un certain point de vue
pas et est devenu le synonyme de l'ordre
de l'existant de l'ordre existant par
exemple monsieur blanc caire disant
qu'il faut une tenir républicaine exigé
tenue républicaine exige est bon c'est
une blague enfin comment dire il n'y a
qu'à en rire mais moi je des prises très
au sérieux quand même par delà le fait
que je me suis marré parce que plan
caire ne rate pas une tenue républicaine
exige et ça veut dire que républicaine
fonctionne dans cette phrase dans ce
syntagme comme synonyme de correct
c'était à l'occasion parce qu'on
critiquait détenus on voyait le nom
brille chez l'homme mais voilà tout à
fait donc il n'avait pas être donc tenu
républicains exigent est tenue correcte
exigée république et décale correct
républicaine et gala correction
républicaine égale l'ensemble des normes
et des lois républicaines en fait égal
républicain égale l'ordre et par exemple
monsieur darmanin va nous dire les
casseurs la rencontre s'en prenant aux
casseurs dans une manif de gilet jaune
ou je ne sais plus quel manif qui avait
qui avait cassé des vitrines les les
horribles casseurs qui avaient cassé
deux vitrines eh bien monsieur darmanin
nous dit quand il casse quand les
casseurs cas s'ils cassent la république
mais ça c'est un autre alors ça c'est
encore plus intéressant parce que dans
ce cas là ça veut dire que république
égale vitrine en cassant des vitrines
ils cassent la république et que donc
bien sûr la république c'est l'ordre et
l'ordre social qu'il faut encore
protégés c'est quand même toujours
l'ordre capitaliste c'est à dire celui
on peut faire de bonnes affaires il faut
protéger les magasins
il faut protéger nos affaires il faut
protéger nos intérêts voilà voilà ce que
veut dire sous couvert de république il
s'agit quand même toujours de défendre
ceux ci mais au fond ce que vous leur
reprochez ce que vous reprochiez
d'ailleurs déjà dont il sort de ta
bêtise au la bourgeoisie libérale aux
électeurs des manuels macron c'est de
nier la réalité sociale et le fait
qu'elle est structurée par des conflits
et au fond c'est de nier l'histoire
quand il s'entraîne aux casseurs ne
s'intéresse pas à la raison pour
lesquelles ils cassent ils ne
s'intéressent pas à la question pour
l'inde où ils viennent pourquoi font-ils
cela non il constate juste que la
vitrine ne tient plus debout voilà je
pense que ça c'est à la hante encore un
point commun entre mes interlocuteurs
soraliens d'un certain soir lyonnais et
tous les gens dont on est en train de
parler qui occupe beaucoup d'espacé
quand même dans le champ politico
médiatique et on les entend beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup c'est la négation de
l'histoire et je dirais même plus
spécifiquement de l'historicité c'est à
dire tout simplement le fait que les
phénomènes est une histoire à qu'ils
s'inscrivent dans le temps et que donc
six ont une histoire c'est des
phénomènes qui ont été produits et s'ils
ont été produits ces cas des producteurs
et qu'il ya des agents de l'histoire et
qu il faut les identifier et les
resituer alors quand on dit ça ces gens
là ils disent ah là là vous voulez tout
expliquer et donc vous voulez tout
excuser c'est leur grande c'est leur
grande parade une parade qui est d'une
grande grande crétinerie il ya quand
même un moment il faut le dire tout ça
est éminemment crétin de penser qu'à
partir du moment où on fait de
l'histoire on serait là pour excuser les
phénomènes bon on est simplement là pour
les expliquer et en fait pour essayer de
les percevoir dans leur réalité alors
c'est très frappant notamment c'est là
que ces gens là sont des essentialiste
qu'ils brassent des essences qui
seraient des entités agissante
pratiquement dans une espèce dans soit
métaphysique indépendamment de leur
assise historique je cite un peu
longuement dans le livre un entretien de
finkielkraut donné par finkielkraut au
moment du coc vidéo moment du au début
de
l'épidémie dans l'île en faisait une
espèce de premier bilan et ses propos
qui à mon avis d'ailleurs ce sont les
cris et les a transcrits c'est pour ça
que me permet de les citer puisque
l'oral c'est autre chose donc je pense
qu'il a pesé ses mots et c'est un
chef-d'oeuvre cet entretien de d'absence
mans total de l'historicité c'est là
qu'on a toujours l'impression quand on
écoute finkielkraut que les choses
tombent du ciel
il ya des phénomènes qui ont lieu dont
on ne sait pas donc par exemple il
arrive que finkielkraut est comme ça
quelques accents y compris un peu
écologistes on le voit parfois défend
des animaux on l'a entendu défendre un
peu les vaches parce qu'il aime bien les
vaches c'est un des rares points communs
que j'aille finkielkraut notre amour des
vaches mais mais à aucun moment il nous
explique mais qui orchestrent l'élevage
industriel qui le fait au nom de quels
intérêts quels sont les entités réel qui
historiquement ont fait que on à
développer l'élevage industriel avec
tous les dégâts qu'on sait alors c'est
là que tous ces gens s'arrêtent toujours
dans la critique de l'existant mais si
peu de vous attendre leurs proches que
vous faites ici alain finkielkraut je
n'ai pas su pourriez le faire à eric
zemmour ou alain soral qui eux au
contraire ne cesse de brandir l'histoire
alors dû façon parfois même très
complotistes chez alain soral il ya
toujours une explication alors que ce
soit pas la bourgeoisie tel ou tel
groupe
suggérer ou nommés sur toujours
responsable de tout alors ils font de
l'histoire d'abord il faut voir des
approximations historiques de zemmour je
n'y reviens pas c'est quand même c'est
quand même ça fait c'est toujours un peu
blessant nous ont écoutés par des quand
on a quelques notions d'histoire parce
que c'est vraiment rempli de
falsification première chose la deuxième
chose c'est qu'en fait je pense qu'il
c'est pour ça que j insiste je pense
souvent des gens comme et mourou
cependant là disons du champ
intellectuel brandissent leur amour de
l'histoire il aime l'histoire moi je
pense qu'il n'aime pas l'historicité
parce que si vous écoutez bien le récit
historique que c'est ray moore depuis
maintenant vingt ans comme non-stop à la
télévision avec beaucoup de temps
d'antenne c'est un récit essentialiste
aussi d'ailleurs il ya un tic verbal que
je repère chez zemmour il commence
beaucoup de 3par c'est toujours la même
chose et donc quand il nous parle par
exemple de ce que pourrait être le
brésil ou des choses comme ça chose qui
engagerait les anglais il va nous parler
d'une invariance anglaise que de tout
temps finalement les anglais ont voulu
faire la nique aux français qui a eu via
rivalité immémoriale et donc ils
essentialise l'histoire c'est à dire que
les agents historique pour zemmour sont
des agents invariants et si ce sont des
agents invariants c'est que telle il n'y
a pas d'histoire et donc ces gens là ont
une façon de faire de l'histoire qui nie
le principe même de l'historicité c'est
à dire de la mobilité des choses du fait
que les choses se construit se font se
défont qui a des agents qu'il ya des
situations qui se succèdent qui sont
hétérogènes les unes avec les autres et
qui font que précisément il ya une
histoire mais on nous répète en
permanence qu'il ya quelques entités
comme ça essentiel qui agissent le monde
et qui en fait un petit peu comme les je
le dis aussi d' c'est comme les ce qui
s'affrontaient dans highlander le film
et christophe lambert voilà il ya des
entités immémoriale qui expliquera vers
l'histoire s'affrontent mais de façon
toujours invariante en fait c'est pour
ça qu'un riche c'est pareil chez alain
soral c'est soral soral quand même
comment dire soral a commencé marxiste
et il a quand même de beaux restes il a
quand même gardé certains
réflexes analytique du marxiste qui sont
précisément de resituer les choses
historiquement et après on sait bien on
sait bien ce qui limite soral c'est que
très très vite et elles sont son
discours qui peut être intéressant
historiquement par moment il fait des
grandes comme ça
il élabore des récits historiques qui
sont parfois intéressant mais très vite
vienne vienne être vient de s'affaisser
viennent se dégonfler et viennent
s'abêtir dans la reconvocation d'entités
immémoriale exemplairement identité
juive exemplairement bien sûr c'est ça
qui caractérise antisémite est vraiment
il y aurait eu une essence qui est au
travail chez françois bégaudeau alors ce
serait comme en bas il me semble que il
me semble que je convoque assez peu dans
ma prose ce genre d' entité je crois pas
il me semble que vous avez fait un livre
contre la bourgeoisie par exemple tout à
fait mais mais mais la bourgeoisie c'est
d'abord on aura noté que la bourgeoisie
c'est une classe sociale concrète se
dire que c'est pas au moins on peut
quand même en donner un certain nombre
d'éléments matériels et là elle a une
histoire et après il s'agirait non pas
c'est ce que je faisais dans mon livre
d'ailleurs mon livre était très
descriptif et très narratif 1 il est
passé pas son temps à dire la
bourgeoisie ceci la bourgeoisie cela
implique bande magie particulière
par ailleurs stephen green bourgeoisie
circonstancié est situé et ça c'est très
intéressant c'est ça la clé c'est de
situer toujours son discours de
l'incarner si par exemple je veux de
nouveau vous dire que il est assez
fréquent dans l'histoire que la
bourgeoisie fassent alliance avec le
fascisme je vous parlerai immédiatement
de la prise de pouvoir de mussolini qui
s'est fait très largement avec l'aide du
grand capital est très largement avec
l'escouade ray qui sont allés quand même
démanteler les grèves ouvrières qui a
valu à ce moment là voyez ça sera une
situation historique on fait une pause
françois bégaudeau on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec que françois
bégaudeau qui publie notre joie aux
éditions pauvert c'est la suite
d'histoires de ta bêtise qui était paru
il ya deux ans vous y renvoyer au fond
deux ados il y aurait pas de vraie
opposition dite vous entre les libéraux
et les i libéraux entre les populistes
et les libéraux anti populiste au fond
trempe c'est le vrai visage des manuels
macron oui c'est pour ça que trump et
parfois détesté par une certaine
bourgeoisie centriste parce que en fait
c'est mon 2e je parle du portrait de
dorian gray quoi voilà c'est son vrai
visage c'est bien pour ça qu'elle
qu'elle s'est toujours empressé de
diaboliser trump et de pratiquement de
l'évacuer de son champ de vision comme
choses monstrueuses mais parce que trump
ça n'est jamais que le libéralisme quand
il est sans frein et quand il est d
entraver et tout libéral rêve d'être des
entraves et je veux dire et haineux
centre have que bien malgré lui se donne
des entraves et se donnent des limites
que bien malgré lui que forcé par
parfois des buts sociale ou par un
certain nombre de contraintes mais
globalement l'espèce de libéralisme
décomplexé
que quand il a vu parfois ici comme un
souverainiste qui s'affirmait la fin du
libre échangisme échevelé le contraire
dur et gagner enfin au fond tout à fait
sauf que corsa il me semble que c'est
sans doute un des unes des
approximations contemporaines les plus
ravageuse pour la clarté de la situation
pour une claire compréhension de la
situation le libéral il n'est pas anti
protectionnistes il est comme tout
commerçant le commerçant aime toujours
et déteste toujours les barrières
douanières qui l'entravent lui et aime
beaucoup les barrières douanières qui le
protège donc en bon libéral en bons
marchands en bons marchands en chef
donald trump marchand en chef des états
unis un marchand des marchands bien à
fait ce que tout marche en rêvent de
faire ils à protéger son marché et il a
explosé les marchés des autres
les etats unis ont les moyens de le
faire grâce au dollar et grâce à leur
puissance économique militaire
déclinante certes mais quand même
toujours toujours perdre il ya plein
d'état qui hélas n'ont pas les moyens de
le faire mais si la france avait les
moyens de le faire ils feraient pareil
je veux dire le il enfoncerait les
douanes des autres donc il serait
antiprotectionnistes pour les pays
étrangers et protectionnistes pour eux
mêmes je veux dire donc arrêtons le
marchand n'a pas de principes le
marchand n'a pas de valeur il est ni le
libre échange et c'est sa propre liberté
qu'ils souhaitent et l'entravent de des
commerçants qui sont ses concurrents
donc il est tout à fait il est un
contresens notoire de considérer qu'il y
aurait une une contradiction majeure
entre le libre-échange les
protectionnismes ça dépend où on se
situe ça dépend de quel point de vue on
se place voilà mes françois bégaudeau
pourquoi ça n'est pas la gauche et en
particulier la gauche critique la gauche
radicale dont vous vous sentez proche
même si elles ne sont pas toujours aussi
proches que vous vous sentez proche
d'elle en europe alors pourquoi ça n'est
pas elle qui profitent de la colère des
a satisfait des des frustrations
de la classe peu des classes populaires
ou des classes moyennes c'était une des
choses qui m'intéressait dans l'écriture
de ce livre parce que et ça c'est de
fait un sujet sur lequel je voulais à
peu tourné depuis un certain temps et
donc ses soirées lyonnaises matt m'a
donné l'occasion d'accélérer le
processus d'écriture bon qu'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis 10 20 ans il ya ce
que j'appellerais presque une énergie
contestataires disponibles
alors on va dire en france et à une
énergie contestataires disponibles
laquelle est capté plus par l'extrême
droite ou par d'autres courants que par
effectivement les forces qui au 19e et
au 20e avait plutôt une tendance avait
capté à l'exception notoire quand même
des moments fascistes et nazis et autres
moments mais c'est vrai que la gauche
radicale la gauche communiste la gauche
anarchiste était une grande cape tous de
contestation et d'énergie contestataires
elle est une quelque chose très
performante dans au 19è et au 20e
maintenant cette énergie là elle va
plutôt alors à soral elle va à ce camp
là ou encore une fois une droite
souverainiste ou une droite autoritaire
norrath raciste ou droite l'homophobe
droite misogyne bon alors ça c'est un
vrai sujet et c'est vraiment une raison
pour laquelle j'ai écrit ce bouquin
parce que là j'ai en face de moi je me
dis les quatre que j'ai en face de moi
ce soir là eux en 75 avec la même
énergie contestataires ils finissent au
pc ils finissent au parti communiste où
la ligue communiste révolutionnaire dont
ce n'est pas chez les anarchistes
autonomes et c'est bon donc là encore
une fois les temps ont changé et qu'est
ce qui fait que sa capture est alors je
pense que il ya tout un tas de raisons
ne serait-ce que la première raison elle
est absolument matériel qu'est ce qui
faisait que ces énergies là avaient
tendance à se projeter politiquement
plutôt du côté de la gauche c'est qu'il
y avait des décos accumulation de gens
très constitué par le marché du travail
par l'organisation du travail qui est
qui qui qui comment dire
favorisait la détermination d'un affect
comme un communiste tout simplement par
exemple les usines tout simplement lors
qu'on travaillait on se portaient vers
la gauche travaillait puis on
travaillait ensemble il y avait des
corps alors que le travailleur isolé
alors voilà c'est ça qui me frappe chez
chez lui si mes interlocuteurs lyonnais
sait que je pense que c'est des gens
fondamentalement isolé d'ailleurs ils
ont ils ont voulu très peut me dire de
chaussures leur statut social ce qui en
dit long sur eux et sur leur
indifférence à la chose sociale et au
concret de la chose sociale mais ils
sont isolés et le citoyen isolé bailly
travail isolément quand ils travaillent
effectivement et il rentre chez lui puis
passe sa vie à regarder les vidéos
youtube et là il tombe plutôt sur soral
il tombe pas sur le délégué cgt de
boulogne-billancourt il n'y a pas que ça
d'après ce que vous leur faites dire
dans votre livre il traite la gauche en
général d' hypocrites les bien pensants
c'est la petit île la voix comme la
bourgeoisie au fond là y compris les
fameux bobo la grande entourloupe de 2 c
la confusion des confusions de ces trois
ou quatre dernières décennies c'est que
une certaine gauche que je regardais
beaucoup dans l'histoire de ta bêtise
une gauche qui a beaucoup voté ps une
gauche centre gauche qui s'est précipité
dans le maquereau nisme en 2017 a
longtemps été considéré par ces gens là
les gens dont on parle comme la gauche
c'était ça la gauche la gauche et sos
racisme s'était bhl dans les années 80
c'était tout ça mais je veux dire ces
gens là ont toujours été considérée par
la gauche de gauche comme n'étant pas de
gauche mais donc effectivement ça ça a
complètement injectés dans le cerveau de
ces jeunes gens l'idée que la gauche
c'est des espèces de donneurs de leçons
avec une petite main sur la veste pour
dire que c'est pas bien le racisme ou
des gens qui font du marketing
féministes ou des gens qui font la gay
pride ou des choses comme ça c'est à
dire autant de comment dire de
protubérances folklorique d'enjeux
sociétaux auquel je tiens beaucoup par
ailleurs les luttes de minorités sont
absolument central dans mon imaginaire à
moi en tout cas dans mon paysage
politique mais elles ont parfois été
comment dire capté aussi par une
certaine gauche bien pensante bourgeoise
et de la pire des manières sur le mode
effectivement du sermon morale alors que
moi je me considère et je pense que
c'est le premier geste de marx
d'ailleurs le premier geste
intellectuelle de marx c'est de dire
c'est d'en finir avec des
positionnements morale de la gauche ce
qu'il appelait les gueux liens de gauche
à l'époque c'est ça le premier geste
donc la gauche marxiste n'est pas moral
précisément pas or ces gens là
effectivement ça leur a échappé ça
n'aura échappé qu'il existait une gauche
qui ne pouvait pas être taxé de bien
pensante et de donneuse de leçons qui
était la gauche marxiste ça leur a
échappé parce que cette gauche là elle a
été très largement mise sous le sous le
tapis dans les années 80 90 2000 bon
pour des raisons objectives pas par des
raisons de de fatigue interne et
intrinsèque aussi parce qu'il ya eu
quand même une grande entreprise de
dévaluation totale du discours
communiste de l'espace public
on est on est presque contemporains vous
et moi donc on a bien que lui ça dans
les années 80-90
mission de la lutte des classes oui mais
même dans les discours il était
absolument impossible de reconvoquer le
lexique marxiste ou le lexique de la
lutte des classes quoi c'était c'était
c'était interdit puisque l'urss avait
perdu puis toute façon on connaissait
les carnages du goulag bon tout à fait
légitime d'ailleurs bon donc
effectivement les jeunes qui se sont
formés politiquement dans les années
2000 ils n'ont pas eu à disposition ce
discours là et donc ils ont amalgamé
cette gauche qui est maintenant
d'ailleurs très largement qui a fait son
coming out de droite et de centre-droit
et de libéral ils ont amalgamé cette
gauche-là et la gauche en général elle
est effectivement ça les a pas rendu
extrêmement comment dire bienveillants
vis-à-vis de ce que eux considéraient
comme comme la gauche c'est une des
explications il en a évidemment plein
d'autres un jeu je pense même moi je je
subodore chez mon interlocuteur
privilégié qui savent que j'appelle m
parce qu'il y avait un peu un chef de
bande en face de moi une généalogie
social qui ne le portaient pas à épouser
des idées plutôt de gauche je 28 que il
vient plutôt d'un milieu de petits
commerçants ou d'indépendants qui sont
en général des contextes sociaux qui
produisent plutôt de la pensée de droite
ou qui produisent de la colère est au
fond la colère brut pour vous n'a pour
politique que la vengeance
elle a pas de plan en fait elle n'a pas
de plan pour rétablir une identité
française que vous considérez comme
fantasme et elle n'a pas de plan pour
tout ça
demain vous donner les clés du pays à
soral pour vous il n'a pas de plan il a
pas de plan ou alors par des 11 petits
tas il a vraiment pas de plan réalisable
petit b 6e mais en fait vraiment
véritablement de réaliser quelque chose
comme un plan alors là c'est une
boucherie c'est une boucherie parce que
quand ils arrivent heureusement assez
rarement dans l'histoire que ces gens là
est la possibilité effective de réaliser
leur fantasmagorie en tout cas de leur
donner un début d'incarnation ça donne
ça donne comme par hasard une solution
finale ça donne comme par hasard de
l'extermination d'un oui bien sûr de les
gérer ce serait arrivé beaucoup plus
souvent que ça certes tout à fait mais
je vais en tout cas le point ultime
c'est l'extermination parce qu'il s'agit
effectivement je veux dire pour réaliser
ses terres pour donner une réalité à
quelque chose qui ne peut pas en avoir
il faut que je jeûne il réel il faut que
je l'ex termine donc lavées ne peut pas
y avoir de politique fasciste autre que
exterminatrice en fait donc ne
souhaitons pas ça mais mais c'est
surtout que la colère je pense moi je
parle surtout de la colère non pas au
sens où elle n'aurait pas de plan mais
au sens où elle même n'indique rien
quant à l'identité politique de celui
qui est en colère de celui qui est sujet
à la colère et la colère à la chose la
mieux partagée du monde et donc la
colère n'est pas l'apanage de la gauche
par exemple contrairement à ce que
parfois on entend du côté des militants
de gauche il faut est en colère la
colère c'est un carburant la côte-nord
la colère c'est sans doute un carburant
mais on ne sait jamais de quel bolide on
ne sait jamais quelle voiture fait
avancer le carburant de la colère en ce
moment j'ai l'impression que la masse de
colère à disposition dans la société
française
s'actualise plutôt dans les mouvements
réactionnaires plutôt dans les
mouvements autoritaire je dirais pas et
pas dans des mouvements émancipateur
donc je me méfie d' en tout cas je pense
qu' il n'y a pas de politique
d'émancipation si on s'en tient à la
seule colère il faut y ajouter d'autres
affecte mais vous parlez d'un blog big
autoritaire qui rassemblerait au fond
l'extrême droite la droite et une partie
du centre droit et du centre gauche mais
alors c'est peut-être il n'ya peut-être
que moi mais moi j'ai l'impression que
je vois une envie de mesures
autoritaires chez tout le monde y
compris
dans la gauche radicale dans la gauche
critique dans l'extrême gauche chez les
féministes pas tout mais chez certaines
chez les écologistes j'en vois beaucoup
surtout seuls les purs écologistes ils
veulent des mesures autoritaires parce
que sinon ils ont l'impression que rien
ne changera et que le réchauffement
climatique sera une catastrophe donc
j'ai l'impression que c'est la mode
d'aujourd'hui et de vouloir tout à coup
que le bloc autoritaire ce soit juste
d'en face est-ce que ça n'est pas au
fond mettre des oeillères pour ne pas
regarder ce que par ailleurs on cajole
alors là il faut faire un effort
conceptuel de clarification parce que
sinon effectivement là vous venez de
produire une réflexion qui est confuse
you nantes c'est à dire évidemment
rapidement tout où tous les camps
seraient autorités est certaine manière
et donc si tous les cours sont
autoritaires mais le signifiant et puis
beaucoup de sens très bien et ses ombres
devait redonner un peu de sens que
j'appelle moi pensent et autoritaire
c'est celle qui considère que l'autorité
est une fin en soi est une fin en soi et
notamment il faut faire autorité sur les
classes populaires qui s'agite un peu
sur les gens qui menace l'ordre
propriétaires sur les gens il s'agit de
faire autorité sur des gens pour calmer
leurs ardeurs calme et leur énergie et
préserver l'existant
sécurité y compris l'absolu pourrait
suivre dit un identitaire voudra mettre
hors d'état de nuire avec autorité et
d'autorité les minorités dont ils
considèrent qu'ils sont en train de
nuire à l'homogénéité ethnique et
culturelle de son pays par exemple voilà
s'agit toujours de faire autorité et
c'est une fin en soi une fois qu'on les
aura mis hors d'état de nuire eh bien
nous aurons fait ce que nous voulons
dans le cas des écologistes par exemple
c'est quand même une extension du
domaine de l'autorité que vous proposez
ce sont eux qui font autorité ce sont
eux les autoritaires les forces
capitalistes qui en ce moment sont en
train de saccager vivent pas ce que je
veux dire c'est quand même pas autre
chose désolée c'est pas moi qui vivais
déglingué les terres entières épuisé les
sols pollués des eaux pour faire du
profit et pour toujours être dans la
course à la croissance c'est pas moi
c'est c'est quand même des forces du des
forces capitalistique des faut quand
même le dire quoi et il s'agit
effectivement des mettre hors d'état de
nuire de les mettre hors d'état de nuire
pour préserver le vivant c'est à dire
que ce sont eux qui font autorité sur la
vie ce sont eux qui font autorité sur
les corps sur les animaux sur les plans
sur la faune sur la flore sur les sols
sur tout ce qu'on veut sur l'air et sur
les glaciers par par voix conséquents p
c'est ce sont eux les autoritaires et
nous nous voudrions simplement comme
disait à peu près 10 h nous sommes des
affirmatif mais parfois pour affirmer
quelque chose en l'occurrence affirmé la
vie il faut dire non au nom pour pour
affirmer le oui il faut dire non au nom
donc nous voulons imprimer une autorité
sur les autoritaires d'accord le refrain
de la trahison des élites
en tenez notamment pas les gilet jaune
vous ne vous privez pas du tout pour
vous les élites ont jamais trahi le
peuple puisqu'elles ont toujours été en
lutte contre le peuple tout à fait non
je sais encore un écart de langage toi
on se refait pas c'est un peu ma ma
petite mayonnaise à moi de toujours
essayer de corriger les écarts de
langage comme un instituteur de la
troisième république
trahison des élites et un écart parce
que on trahit quelque chose quand on
s'est engagé à quelque chose qu'on
travaille toujours un engagement je je
je t'ai fait croire que j'allais
l'épouser et finalement j'en épouser une
autre j'ai trahi ma promesse mais parce
que la première gelée énoncés donc si
les élites ont trahi ça veut dire
qu'elles se sont engagées quelque chose
si elles ont trahi le peuple sait
qu'elle s'était engagée à servir le
peuple elles se sont pas engagés à
servir le peuple elles ont vaguement
dans des éléments de langage de meetings
politiques dit que c'était du côté du
peuple en france ça c'est la sauce
politique habituelle et il ya que les
imbéciles comme disait l'autre je sais
plus si c'est pascouau chirac ou que
sais-je qui disait les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui y croient très
bonnes phrases bon donc croire qu'il
puisse y avoir une trahison des élites
c'est crois qu'ils ont promis quelque
chose les élites ne promettent rien les
élites veulent se conserver en tant
qu'élite elles veulent protéger leurs
intérêts et et perdurer en tant que tel
donc quand le maquereau nisme par
exemple on en a dit macron avait trahi
le peuple et les maquereaux n'a jamais
trahi le peuple il a fait très
exactement et autant qu'il a pu malgré
les circonstances il a très exactement
réaliser le programme libéral qui était
le sien pendant sa campagne enfin je le
savais très bien par qui il a été élu
par qui il avait été soutenu il n'est
donc pas du tout étonnant je trouve que
au contraire macron a été hélas
absolument fidèle à ce qu'il avait
promis absolument fidèle d'une grande
honnêteté au bout du compte de ce point
de vue là donc et encore une fois par
ailleurs je pense qu'il ya une grande
bêtise alors là pardon un politique et
une grande mais compréhension de ce que
c'est que la confiture alité social de
considérer que la classe dominante
pourrait véritablement vouloir servir
les classe et la classe affaires et
leurs sages là je pense que là là il ya
quand même une méconnaissance alors pour
le coup de l'histoire et de choses qui
s'est répété en permanence et une
méconnaissance ou une féminisation de ce
que c'est quand même que l'ordre des
propriétaires dont on sait très bien que
dès qu'ils se sentent menacés on sait
très bien sûr qui dit ap mais il ya une
demande patriarcat aussi vous le voulez
voquer dans votre livre il ya notamment
chez vos interlocuteurs lyonnais ce soir
là une envie du père ben oui alors ça
moi je pense que c'est le moi j'aime
bien creuser ça c'est pour ça que je
pars de jean précis des vrais corps que
j'avais en face de moi parce que moi
j'aime bien faire des ramener un peu les
choses à des à des affects alors que je
sais pas s'il ya un affect maîtres chez
eux mais en tout cas s'il y en a un je
crois que c'est celui-là et je pense que
c'est un rapport au masculin je dirais
plus globalement au masculin ça vraiment
sale et titi d'ailleurs on le voit bien
dans la dans la fachosphère mais y
compris d'ailleurs encore une fois dans
tout un pan du bloc autoritaire je veux
dire il ya quand même bon il suffit de
leur parler de féminisme pendant 20
secondes ça les rend dingue quoi je leur
réaction épidermique et tout et tout à
fait extraordinaire donc on voit bien
qu'on touche un point sensible et qu'on
est peut-être dans le noyau sensible de
la faire et qui est un rapport à leur
propre virilité à la masculinité en
général est alors exemplairement donc au
père le père qui est quand même aussi
l'entité de la pensée autoritaire il
faut des pères il faut des pères de la
nation comme de gaulle il faut des pères
de la nation qui régule un peu tout ça
il faut qu'on se mette tous derrière un
papa en chef bon donc là je crois qu'on
est dans une zone voilà je crois qu'il
avait d'ailleurs rappelé dans mon
dernier passage ici propos d'un livre
d'entretiens sur lequel on avait parlé
il faut toujours rappeler que les
premiers livres de zemmour et soral sont
des livres qui porte sur le féminisme
qui sont des livres antiféministe donc
la matrice finalement de zemmour comme
de soral pour parler que de ces penseurs
du bloc autoritaire et c'est exactement
ça la ligne de front pour eux c'est
quand même la société se féminise donc
être ceux des virils hisse donc elle se
castres et c est là je pense que j'ai eu
à faire à des jeunes gens qui comme
beaucoup d'autres d'ailleurs on sait que
c'est une tendance assez lourde en ce
moment dans une certaine jeunesse
occidentale ont l'air très très inquiets
du côté de leur virilité en laye en
l'air tout à fait effrayé par cette
espèce d'assaut d'émancipation féminine
dont il considère que ça valait destitué
et que l'on va plus pouvoir être des
hommes bons et effectivement il y en a
un moment qui me demandent qu'à vais pas
parler de toute la soirée et d'un seul
coup il me pose la seule question qui me
posent la soirée c'est ouais mais bon et
la gpa tu en penses quoi voilà le
premier truc que je suis d'ici mais
vraiment on parlait pas du tout ça mais
pourquoi toi tu me parles de ça tu étais
pas lesbienne moi non plus il est une
heure du matin on est à lyon on a bu
trois pintes et tu me parles de gpa fin
je tu crois c'est vraiment pourquoi
c'est ton sujet en fait moi je ne
concerne pas que lesbienne je les fais
mais je veux dire dans son esprit à lui
c'était bien ça ce qui m'inquiétait
c'était quand même que deux femmes
puissent avoir un enfant alors là c est
que c'est plutôt la pma les gps
acoustique
services sexuels non mais j'ai juste
fait une erreur c'est bien de pma qui
meublent dangereux de confusion à mon
tour donc bien sûr de pma et donc et
bois je lui dis mais qu'est ce qu'est ce
qui te prends mais pourquoi tu me pose
cette question c'est ce que j'ai fait
pendant toute la soirée d'ailleurs
plutôt que de leur répondre sur les
sujets qui le convoquait je leur disais
mais pourquoi ce sujet vous intéresse
pourquoi vous vous emballez dans ce
genre de merdier alors que c'est
vraiment pas le problème en ce moment du
côté de la réalité bon alors je lui dis
et là il finit par me lâcher sans doute
un peu aidé par un peu d'alcool que
qu'un enfant a besoin d'un père alors ça
a été presque le dernier mot de la
soirée comme ce club espèce de comment
dire de de rosebud finale kiki expliqué
presque rétroactivement tout le reste
quoi comme si c'était le noeud alors moi
je n'aime pas les explications un peu
comme ça univoque mais je pense que ça
tourne quand même beaucoup autour de
saint staff r nous votre derniers mois
vous c'est la joie vous dites me font
entre vos interlocuteurs et vous ce qui
s'interpose c'est la joie quel joueur
elle vous dit dans le livre mais je
pense que la joie il ya ya ya une mode
joie vient quand même d'un lexique
plutôt chrétien et dans le christianisme
il ya une différence entre par exemple
l'espoir et l'espérance est pas la même
chose l'espoir c'est quand on se
projette sur ce qui pourrait être en
espérant donc que ce qui sera sera
plutôt positif l'espérance et passe à
l'espérance est pas l'espoir l'espérance
c'est le sentiment immédiat maintenant
de sa foi et de sa vitalité et du et et
que le christianisme peut appeler joie
donc c'est le sentiment ici et
maintenant de sa propre puissance de sa
propre puissance est ce que j'essaie de
préconiser un peu dans cette deuxième
partie qui parle davantage de monde mon
périmètre de pensée de mes amis je
dirais de mes amis politiques de mes
camarades c'est qu'il me semble
caractériser caractériser ce camp où cet
espace disons d'amitié
c'est tout ce dont nous avons déjà été
capable tout ce dont nous avons déjà été
par là notre puissance effective et
c'est vrai que j'ai demandé un moment à
mai à mes interlocuteurs soraliens je
leur ai dit mais sur quelles
réalisations effectives pouvez vous
appuyer sur quels héraults véritable qui
ne soient pas des héros de fantasmagorie
parce que là il me parle des croisades
et tout ça ils vont sur la croisade
napoléon jeanne d'arc bon moi je moi je
moi je sais que tous les matins je peux
m'appuyer j'en fais la liste un moment
nous avons pu nous avons pu tout ce que
nous avons pu nous avons plus jean
patrick manchette voilà c'est un
écrivain que vous connaissez écrivain
marxiste libertaire de giens var voilà
mes jeux manchette est le produit de
cette tradition manchettes et fabriqué
par cet espace et qui vous pourrez vous
énoncez vous le reconnaissez vous même
qui a beaucoup d'écrivains de droite
tout à fait mais par contre ce que ne
pourraient pas oui mais je pense que par
exemple françois tosquelles et s
françois tosquelles yes républicains
espagnols anarchistes et vire et bien
sûr par le franquisme et il arrive en
france et il est psychanalyste et idées
marxistes entre autres choses et il
trouve un il atterrit à saint-alban
saint-alban c'est un asile où on a
laissé les fous on les laisse crever de
faim parce qu'on est en 1940 on va
évidemment le petit nice mais pas et pas
et pas promptement vouloir nourrir des
fous donc on les laisse crever de faim
eu beaucoup de fous qui sont morts
pendant sous l'occupation dans un souper
cynisme et ben françois tosquelles
liesse en tant que marxiste anarchistes
espagnols et psychanalyste va s'occuper
d'eux il va il va lancer une espèce
d'autogestion par les fous qui eux mêmes
vont se mettre à cultiver et à pouvoir
produire par eux mêmes ce qui leur
permettra de survivre et puis après il
va inventer des exemples plus connus
jusqu'à la commune alors tu as fait mais
justement il neigera du patriotisme me
dites vous oui
comme on veut nous le faire croire mais
non non tout à fait alors ça ça débat
sur le fait que la commune puisse être
lue comme un mouvement patriote c'est
vraiment mauvais risques qui fait qu'il
est parfois récupéré par l'extrême à 2
voilà encore un élément de confusion
vraiment pénible que j'ai c'est de
dissiper dans le bouquet ab pour en
revenir à ce sur quoi je m'appuie bien
sûr jeu et je prends ces exemples-là
l'arrêt la constitution de 1793 bien sûr
la social de 1848 bon et bien sûr la
commune mais par delà sa moi je sais que
pour moi même en tout cas ce qui
entretient la joie ce qui entretient mon
espérance
c'est précisément le sentiment que
j'arrive derrière tout un tas d'autres
amis qui peuvent être parfois des
personnes un carnet qui ont fait des
choses concrètes et donc ça peut être
effectivement françois tosquelles yes au
même titre que jean marie straub et
danièle huillet couple de cinéastes
marxiste magnifique des années 70 80 90
c'est à tous ces gens moi que je pense
et et je crois que en termes de
réalisations d'émancipation que dire où
est ce qu'il y a une expérience shia
passe du côté de l'extrême droite
qu'elle serait l'équivalent d'une
expérience chiha passe du côté d'extrême
droite banon a donc donc mon pauvre m et
ses copains tu as quand il se lève le
matin et donc n'ont pas beaucoup de
choses à contempler qui puisse les
rendre joyeux et les rendre affirmatif
pour affirmer des amitiés ils ne peuvent
que se se ressasser des inimitiés alors
ils regardent des vidéos alors ils
regardent des émissions de télé et
regarde la dernière prestation de bhl
chez ruquier ou de tel autre triste sire
et puis le déteste et pis le passe entre
eux et donc ils se nourrissent comme ça
dans une sorte d'inimitié c'est encore
une fois on en revient au début le noyau
affectif et le choeur affectif de de ces
gens c'est quand même un refus c'est un
refus moi je pense que on peut
construire une énergie politique à
partir de choses qu'on a affirmé qu'on
m'aime après il sort de ta bêtise
c'était là la bourgeoisie libérale là
c'est plutôt ceux qui n'aiment pas la
bourgeoisie libérale mais qui sont
plutôt de droite ou d'extrême droite
vous commencez un peu à parler de la
gauche radicale dans notre joie c'est
pas très long et il nous reste très peu
de temps mais pourquoi est ce qu'il vous
aime pas est-ce que vous ne cessez de
faire du bien en tout cas dans ces deux
livres et et vous reconnaissez qu'il ne
vous aime pas beaucoup rire j'exagère un
peu j'ai quand même pas mal de
témoignages d'amis ici dans ce camp puis
bon j'ai pas mal d'amis tout court donc
tout va bien alors après il y aurait
plein de choses à dire et finalement on
n'a pas le temps donc je le ferai pas
maintenant et je pense que je le ferai
dans un prochain livre demander si c'est
tout mais
peut-être que il ya des raisons pas
reluisante qui seraient des raisons de
conflits dualité de chant comme on dit
en sociologie bon c'est finalement d il
ya départ il ya un marché de la delà de
la production conceptuel de gauche
radicale et donc quand vous arrivez
dedans vous prenez un marché ah oui et
vous prenez une part de marché d'où les
rivalités depuis toujours il va livrer
le narcissisme des petites différences
qui fait qu'on déteste nous toujours
beaucoup plus celui qui nous ressemble
et c'est bon je passe là dessus et des
trucs encore moins reluisant mais je
passe aussi le truc le plus noble c'est
ce dont j'essaie de parler c'est que je
crois que je passe toujours pour une
sorte d'électron libre et les jeux jeux
ce que je suis plus ou moins d'ailleurs
peu importe mais enfin bon comment dire
je suis pas un militant pur jeu loin de
là mais vraiment pas en plus je m'occupe
de trucs tout à fait inutile genre le
cinéma je fais un peu de casse de
critiques de cinéma j'ai écrit un cahier
je fais des romans enfin on peut pas
compter sur moi quoi et je crois que
par-delà montpetit cas personnel
inintéressant il y aille a parfois dans
le périmètre de gauche radicale un
malentendu ou un embarras vis-à-vis de
de l'entité individuelle alors que moi
je tiens profondément que comment dire
les forces de l'émancipation non pour
horizon que la libération des individus
et de rien d'autre que ça donc là je
pense que ça ça mérite une petite
discussion que j'essaie d'avoir dans ce
livre mais que j'essaierai d'avoir de
façon plus consistante dans le prochain
projet peut-être peut-être dans sept ans
c 'est pas imminent merci françois
bégaudeau d'être venu passer une heure
dans cette émission notre joie ça vient
de paraître aux éditions pover merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]